the Joe Rogan experience you know one of
the things that always stood out to me
about you was how composed you are and
you rarely get emotional you know even
like I remember when you fought Carl
Froch Carl Froch hit you clearly after
the bell and clearly in a fight you were
dominating and you just went like this
mmm you said you didn't get mad you
didn't go [ __ ] you you didn't nothing
you took that punch this one turn and
just went back to your corner like it
never happened like you just just wiped
it clean like that's not gonna benefit
me to get upset here how did you develop
that kind of composure I think one thing
that my dad and Virg did really well
from me and my brother Jonathan who box
with me for many years they gave us
mental reps like like I'd be driving in
the car or riding in the car with Virg
on my dad and they'd be telling me
listen man when you get in that ring
when you spar today man listen I do try
to hit you low you make sure you get
your respect you don't accept this in
the ring like this is these are things
that I was taught I was like I was
taught to be a warrior at a young age
and oftentimes trainers will train the
body but they don't train the mind so
pleasure and also life experiences
things that I've been through with my
mom my dad and just just all that kind
of stuff plus my internal makeup the way
you know God made me all of that
combined I never had to be the loudest
talker in the room because I knew that
all that all the stuff the real stuff is
in me it's not on me so I'm the type
that you hit me like that
I'm a smile at you I got you we got
another round to fight sir so my anger
might might get back i'ma get it within
the confines of these rules but you
gonna feel me
Kovalev knocked me down all right I got
you a smile you're embarrassed you're
mad you're frustrated everything and
then that eight second that eight count
you again you feel all every emotion you
could possibly feel but inside I knew
like now you're gonna have to knock me
out
because I'm coming to get it so some of
it is he Nate some of it was taught and
then throughout the course of my life
and career I was I was given the mental
reps a son watch him right here watch
how someone so pushed his hand down
he got right back in his face not out of
the remember in the ring teaching me and
showing me in highlighting what a strong
mind was and what a weak mine wasn't
typically the weak mind was the loudest
talker
don't get me wrong I love a guy that can
talk to talking back it up it's not a
lot of those in the game know MMA or box
so I'm afraid of the guy who's not
saying very much the guy that's hard to
read the guy we're trying to figure out
man as it was up with him
that's the guy I'm concerned about the
loudest talker I usually get excited
when guys used to just go over the top
I'd like that same thing with cochlear
fought the first fight close could win
either way but from the time the first
fight ended until the time the second
second fight started I learned more
about that guy in that period of time
than I did in any round that I fought a
man he said so much and I was poking
holes in and I was crying I was just
sitting back and everybody was miss
reading the silence or it's Garrity he's
not gonna check the read man I'm just
sitting like you know taking notes man
this guy's keep talking keep talking he
was just saying things I was like this
is a weakness now if he would've said
look I felt like I won that fight I felt
like they robbed me I'm coming back to
get it and then went silent went dark
now I'm like man this dude was getting
ready we got we got to tighten up kept
talking man sometimes I talking to
reveal a little bit too much about
yourself what did you see from the
talking just excuse my kid he didn't
give me any credit he started I mean if
it wasn't the rent and I'm exaggerating
but just for the case of emphasis you
know if the ring lights weren't too
bright the referee was against him if it
wasn't the referee it was the judges
like he never owned up to anything that
he did wrong but if I go back to the
research that we did about him before we
even fought him the first time that
lying devil will be heard the guy he
doesn't he doesn't he doesn't take
ownership of anything he blames
everybody anytime anything goes wrong
he's a front-runner
he's a bully he's this he's that that
confirmed everything we had heard so
you're the crusher
you're Sergey Kovalev you knocked me
down in the second round not the 11th
the second round you were supposed to
finish me sir the fact that we're even
talking about a fight being close
like that I finished the fight that's
bothering you that debt that's a chick
that's that's chipping away at this
whole crusher thing that you've been
that you've been living on and he
couldn't handle it instead of owning it
he blamed John David Jackson he blame
this guy blame that guy that's a sign of
weakness man now strength hmm were you
impressed with him getting through the
eighth round against yard and his last
fight I wouldn't say impressed I mean
listen he he hasn't gotten where he's
gotten by not being tough so generally
speaking he's tough he's a tough
individual to a point I wasn't surprised
I was just I was like dude if you ever
if a fighter has ever been saved by the
bell you were just Saved by the Bell
like you were a punch a punch or two
away from getting you know getting
stopped in your home country and in your
home your home city hometown that was
the only kind of like jarring part of it
and then my next thought was can he
recover is he going to be able to
physically recovered then
psychologically come back and try to get
back what y'all took from him in that
round and he did that so he showed me
that he still got something in the tank
but he's uh he was the right way to say
it he's fading fast like he's fading
right before our eyes he doesn't have
the reaction he doesn't have I still
very good he still he still can beat a
lot of guys but he's fading fast if
there's a Canelo fight on the table I
think he should take it and ride off in
the sunset man go enjoy your life well
it was interesting how you exposed him
in the second fight because the body
shots the body shots have been a
weakness like since then everybody has
kind of compromised his body they've
found what you found out is that
something you knew going into the second
fight or did you know it in the first
fight like when when do that in the
first fight did you problem with me and
there in the first fight the first
couple rounds I was thinking too much
and his Duke came out fast so I'm
thinking like I'm trying to get my range
and he's I look and he's it's not that
he's like this crazy power puncher is
just that he's sharp and he's accurate
so I'm like catching shots I'm getting
hit with jabs I'm trying to figure he
didn't give me a chance to think in the
poem I got hit with the right hand I'm
like I said bro so that was the best
thing that could happen to me like I
said earlier and then you saw the body
attack
get implemented so that was always the
game plan I won the second fight with
everything that I did in the first fight
like we unlocked the code in the first
fight and when people couldn't get past
a knockdown rights they failed to look
at the you know the next ten Ram
[Applause]